what do you want for Christmas this year
I never asked for anything nervousness I
don't like it makes you feel weird
really yeah like I've never been like
that it makes me uncomfortable christmas
gives me really uncommon
I don't know I don't need it I mean I
don't know I I don't know I feel weird
that I'm getting a gift on Christmas I'm
like I didn't do anything with it you
know what I mean so I just I don't know
it makes me feel like uncomfortable and
I feel like whenever I say I love
something it looks like I don't like it
and I can't help it because I really do
like it I am trying too hard the show
that I like it so it's just awkward okay
you're turning 18 you're gonna be legal
here next year did you know that I just
let you know that oh my god well I'll be
a legal adult in America which that's
right so yeah that's cool and I'm not a
drinker no it's not excited oh I don't
really care about the drinking thing but
yeah this has been a big year for you
yeah you were on tour with Katy Perry
that experience for you how was it that
was wild I'm incredibly grateful for
that and like for Katy to like take a
brand new artist it's only been out a
year on to her tour I think was really
cool of her and like totally like a big
chance for me and like I owe a lot to
her I feel like just because she did
that for me and like I I'm so incredibly
getting grateful for that opportunity
and I wouldn't have found that anywhere
else I don't think a lot of people want
like a brand new artists opening up for
them and that was a really cool thing of
her and just I think
she's so talented and she was so
talented it's such a young age and she
wanted it so bad I think she understands
what it's like to be a new artist just
you know what I mean and I from her like
documentary she put out a long time ago
I remember watching non-being like that
is so sick like you know she started
from like solo and like totally just
built herself up and created this entire
career for herself so I really look up
to her as an artist and I think she is
so incredibly talented and beautiful and
amazing did she give you any advice what
you guys wrote or you know is she I
think from watching her that was like
the best advice she could have given me
is just watching her every night and
watching her confidence grow like first
show to my lash on that run and also
like watching the show you know in the
beginning
every like with hurt so much production
you know it started off like there would
be like production errors in the
beginning and how she handled that was
so beautiful and like so graceful and
she just she pulled it off so well and
handled it so well so that was the best
lesson that I could have learned is how
to handle stuff going wrong whenever
you're on stage and she handles it just
incredibly it's so easy for her up there
and like she has so much fun you talking
about being on stage and being in front
of your fans and they're singing your
songs that must have an amazing
influence on you as a new artist it's
really incredible and like my favorite
my favorite thing about being a new
artist is you know it's kind of
difficult in a way to go out in front of
a crowd that doesn't know you and you
can tell that they don't know you in a
way and like you can you can kind of as
you get your energy up and as you start
to connect with people that don't know
you you can see them catch on and that's
you know when they start engaging with
your music and that's probably the most
beautiful thing to see it's like either
if it's somebody that puts their full
night on first to put it up in the air
or anything it's a really like rewarding
feeling as a brand new artist to see
somebody like engage and enjoying my
music as somebody that maybe didn't
really understand as I came out or
wasn't as excited whenever I came out on
stage and then they start to engage and
catch their attention and that's
probably the coolest thing about being a
new artist for me is gaining those fans
you know music's been part of your life
your family and music now for yourself
how does that feel for you is it your
own is a gyro reflection of who you are
yeah absolutely I think I mean I started
writing music when I was 15 in the
studio and only one producer wanted to
work with me is his name is Jason no
Suzy oh he's doing massive hits right
now Thunder with imagine dragons he
actually
co-wrote on my song slow with matome ax
which it's crazy and that came full
circle circle because we haven't put
anything out together yet and that was
our first one in matome it just came out
and I have a full basically album with
him that I never from when I was 15 and
so I've always wanted my music to
reflect on Who I am and I've always
wanted to be really upfront with my fans
you know what I mean and always wanted
to like really be able to engage with
them and for them to know like who I am
as a person and not just an artist just
Who I am all the time on and off camera
yeah who are you I'm a mess
I mean I just I just want them to know
that like you know I'm not just like a
figure doing music like I am a real 18
year old and you know I'm not 17 year
old like that you know wakes up in the
morning the same way that they do and I
get ready the same way they do and go
through my day the same way that they do
I just might be doing something a little
different you know what I mean and I
might be growing up a little different
then they get to which has pros and cons
so you know I just wanted to always let
them know like Who I am truly and who I
was before my music and how that hasn't
really changed I love that nc-17 first
of all the name don't ask about it it's
a little late
you know talking to Fergie or to it she
took her time with it and she's created
her double Dutchess you know how do you
feel about it I mean I'm so excited like
I said I've been riding since I was 15
yeah
and I've gotten so much new music since
then you know it just keeps getting
added on and I don't want to stop
because this first album there's so much
to me it means so much to me that I'm
being able to put this album out so I
just don't want to rush it I know I was
like it's coming at the end of this year
and like I'm sorry it's running late but
it's just it's been such like it's like
a baby you know what I mean I really
like my little project that I've been
working on for such a long time and I've
been like holding it in for such a long
time that I'm I'm open to waiting a
little longer to get it just the way I
wanted it to come out so it is running a
little behind the plan but I'm working
on it I'm trying but there will be more
music in the new year and excited I
could feel your passion know I love my
you love your music holiday traditions
we eat very early
we're done by three oh we are the turkey
we're not hurt yeah I mean we like we
eat mashed potatoes and corn and veggies
and turkeys therefore whoever wants it
but no we we get done pretty early my
mom wants it done by 3:00 like she's
right like as we're unwrapping gifts
she's putting it in the garbage bag like
all the wrapping paper I love you and I
can't wait four years